[Musique]
je m'appelle charlotte et je pense que
les plus belles découvertes se font au
bout de la rue ce que j'aime c'est
découvrir notre beau pays avec des
personnes exceptionnelles et souvent
insolites
alors je vous emmène avec moi cette
semaine je vous retrouve dans le
département des yvelines nous sommes
offert jce une commune située non loin
de rambouillet j'ai rendez vous avec
eric et ricky les éleveurs très engagé
pour la protection de la nature et
surtout et c'est pour ça que j'avais
envie de le rencontrer in élèves que des
espèces extrêmement rare ou
particulièrement exceptionnelle et c'est
directement chez lui à la ferme que nous
allons le retrouver pour développer ces
thèmes de prédilection le respect de
l'environnement et le local éric est ce
qu'on peut faire un petit retour en
arrière il ya trente ans tu arrives ici
qu'est ce que qu'est ce qu'il ya dans ta
tête qu'est ce que tu as envie de faire
il ya trente ans je recherchais une
une ferme pour pouvoir y mettre mes
chevaux parce que je commençais à faire
du concours du concours haut niveau et
je voulais absolument rester en région
parisienne région de coeur famille est
là depuis très très longtemps et on a eu
la chance de tomber sur un paysan qui
prenait sa retraite qui vendait la ferme
de la petite drogue une ferme de 1780
qui est super rebelle qui est qu on a
essayé de bien retaper avec cette
abreuvoir centrale qui est typique de
trois fermes de la région qui servait à
abreuver les
les chevaux lourds et les boeufs lourds
dont avait besoin d'un polluant pour
faire ces guerres voilà donc les terres
étaient traditionnellement des très
bonnes terres pour engraisser le bétail
donc une première vie avec les chevaux
vont on continue à y avoir des chevaux
ici et puis ensuite la partie élevage
elle est venue comme non quand j'ai pris
ma retraite sportive
j'avais quelques poulinières j'avais on
avait un bon élevage on était dans les
cinq premiers et élevage en france un
sur dix mille éleveurs c'est pas c'était
pas c'était pas mauvais et j'avais tout
ces prairies qu'on avait recréé on a
planté 150 milliards ou signant et déjà
y ait un projet un peu écologique quand
même ah oui de toute façon moi j'ai
toujours considéré qu'il fallait qu'on
protège l'environnement et qu'on
revienne sur un environnement préservé
faire revenir les oiseaux faire revenir
tous les petits mammifères les protéger
et protéger la terre lui redonner de la
terreur à bhl et travailler sur le
vivant du sol ça c'était très important
tous les hivers ont planté quelques
milliers d'arbres à la pioche à la botte
donc on faisait une paire de bottes par
un hiver on trouve combien de sortes
d'animaux aujourd'hui ici alors j'ai pas
fait le compte exact on trouve pas mal
de races de vaches comme on le verra
tout à l'heure et
on a tout un tas de poule et on a des
cochons aussi un peu particulier c'est
des anciennes écuries j'imagine ce sont
mes premières écuries tout à fait ce
sont mes premières écuries mais
maintenant il ya plus de chevaux on y on
y met des cochons et des poules les
poules à la finition dont regarde jette
un oeil la fameuse la fameuse houdan
voilà qui est en train de se préparer
gentiment pour aller sur les assiettes
du trianon palace pour pour fêter le
centenaire de l'armistice signé à
versailles donc en fait c'est des poules
qui sont promises un destin un peu
exceptionnel
c'était une poule à la base
exceptionnelle faut pas oublier que
c'est une poule qui est plusieurs fois
séculaire c'est une poule qu'on
retrouvait sur la table des plus grandes
selon de l'osr l'empereur les rois les
reines c'était c'était la poule la plus
apprécié à l'époque et ça c'est de la
poule qu'on nourrit avec les invendus du
leclerc rambouillet qui nous fournit en
permanence tous les invendus en fruits
légumes pains à l étage et ont nourri
avec les poules et les cochons j'ai
l'impression qu'elle n'ose pas trop j'ai
noté sur la rue ont fait leur faveur les
impressionne est-ce que tu as remarqué
les oeufs blanc résidents c'est drôle ça
bah ils sont hissés pas les regarder
manger et ça tu as l'habitude de les
manger ses désirs chocolat non ce sont
des oeufs de marans des poules marans
qui font des jeux exceptionnels un jaune
danse et surtout c'était les oeufs
préféré des pâtissiers d'autrefois
parce que plus de goût parce que plus de
goût parce que plus on tue auzits est
parce qu exceptionnelle alors tu sais
quoi
ce soir tu les mangera à la coque et
merci effectivement en rentrant du
tournage j'ai dégusté les eaux tout
simplement à la coque c'était un régal
mais revenons au cool parmi les espèces
rares que posséder ricky lee aller iam
ses manies une poule étonnante d'origine
indonésienne qui a la particularité
d'être entièrement de couleur noire
alors elles sont belles et plus elles
sont exceptionnelles parce que
c'est une souche qui est championne de
france et championne d'europe et les
poules qui gagne les concours elle l'est
gagnent sur quel critère c'est la
bottine sur des critères de beauté sur
le noir il faut qu'elle soit
parfaitement de voir si elles ont un
petit bouc blanc ou un petit bout rouge
c'est mort par contre elles ont des
reflets elles ont des reflets mais elles
ont une hyperpigmentation noir qui sera
de lui avec avec une chair noire des
zones noires c'est étonnant ce étonnant
et c'est très bon tu sais quoi
tu vas mourir la porte du box qui est là
et là tu vas voir un cochon très très
très très particulier regardons ce sont
des cochons laineux du manga lizin
terrifié et donc les ne passe que parce
qu'ils ont de la laine
ils ont la laine sur le dos rare c'est
assez sauvage
en plus ils viennent d'arriver le cochon
laineux c'est un set un cochon d'origine
hongroise et lé chef charcutier sont
tous fous du manga lise la philosophie
de la ferme c'est de vendre aussi bien
en direct aux clients qu'à la grande
distribution
car la grande restauration pour me
donner une autre preuve de la force du
local éric m'entraîne à quelques
kilomètres de là dans le restaurant de
christophe cornier tous les deux se sont
rencontrés il ya quelques années et
c'est vite devenu une évidence de
travailler ensemble et pour le repas de
midi christophe est justement en train
de préparer une poule de houdan
christophe la poule 2 ou dans quelles
sont les particularités qui font que
vous aimez bien là travailler assez que
c'est une poule qui n'existait plus
enfin quasiment plus une voix laïque on
trouve essentiellement sur les tables
royal et qui avec le temps a disparu
mais qui est vraiment à la fort agréable
à travailler en termes de goût c'est
vraiment délicat la cuisse et les deux
ailerons ont été confiées comme on
ferait une cuisse de canard confite
hockey co2 cuisse a été fauchée comme
une poule au pot d'accord une façon de
la poule au pot et ça c était rôti mais
sur le sur la carcasse est quoi l est ce
que vous aimez particulièrement faire me
faire plaisir pour pouvoir faire plaisir
aux gens
[Musique]
alors comment ça s'est passé et comment
vous êtes rencontrés est ce que c'est le
coup de foudre a été immédiat
alors le coup de foudre a été immédiat
ça c'est ça c'est clair de toute façon
quand on quand on goûte la cuisine de
christophe on ne peut être que ravis et
subjugué donc ça c'est clair et
christophe toi qu'est-ce que tu
apprécies particulièrement dans le
travail avec eric est la relation tu
cherches à avoir avec les gens qui te
fournit ces nouvelles actions devraient
effacer comme eric est vrai et sincère
c'est facile mais il y avait rien
attention il est dans les prés il va
regarder d'eva joly va regarder les
poules face à ses doutes après fourguer
de la cam 1 ça c'est pas possible il
vient il vient vérifier
ils demandent ce que commença mange
comme ans a battu il a un souci du
bien-être et de l'alimentation de la
digue main ça s'est passé quelque chose
d'important justement de fait une
dépression qui n'est qua none pour
pouvoir continuer je pense sublimer
encore plus le produit est tout en le
respectant
jusqu'à la fin c'est là où on pourra
voir le
le meilleur du produit mais c'est vrai
je le répète souvent il faudrait qu'on
revoie les méthodes d'abattage en france
notamment en utilisant la méthode tempel
grande hinglé les animaux rentrent ils
sont dans des conditions sans stress et
sans brutalité
jusque jusqu'au terminus donc il ya des
vrais progrès à faire dans ce domaine là
espérons ton appel sera entendu
l'immense île mance l'immense progrès
les avais rabattage à la ferme voire
l'abattage mobile d'abattage affaire mme
christophe milite pour je milite pour
également en tout cas tout faire pour
que notre société reste une société
développée dans lequel nos animaux sont
bien traités nous voici de retour à la
ferme d'eric après les poules il veut me
présenter les races de vaches qui
l'élève est qu on pourrait même dire
qu'ils conservent des races rares
oublier est exceptionnel et pour pousser
loin le concept dans les tables les
vaches écoutent de la musique classique
la sono installée en voie de disparition
elle est la voie d'extinction et parce
qu'il n'en reste que 400 en france 400
mais en france que les gens ne la
connaissent pas que les gens ignorent sa
qualité
on essaie de la faire revivre parce que
si nous ne sommes pas là ou si d'autres
agriculteurs comme moi ne sont pas là
pour acheter des petits broutards pour
les
élevé chez eux eh bien je pense que dans
dix ans elle aura disparu
il n'en restera plus elle et elle est
très rare encore plus rare c'est
l'europe qui est juste derrière nous
cette fameuse vache préhistorique
l'ancêtre de toutes nos vaches celle que
l'on retrouve dessinée
dans la grotte de lascaux dans la grotte
chauvet et puis on a la chance c'est
presque une bête mythologiques
ac c'est une c'est une bête vraiment qui
peuplent notre imaginé en tout cas on a
toujours les dessins de la grotte de
lascaux
il ya un côté un peu étrange parfois
mais de se dire que là si on veut
développer les races il faut aussi les
manger en fait il n'y a pas le choix
y a pas le choix sauf si quelques riffs
personnes veulent en avoir pour faire
beau dans leurs belles propriétés
cette année c'est un animal sauvage il
faut des vrais clôture il faut on a dit
beaucoup de temps les approcher au début
on pouvait pas rentrer dans le rang par
quand il peut il que chargé et là
maintenant ils sont ils sont tous
gentils sont beaucoup plus calmes la
musique le site sont mélomanes j'allais
dire voilà la musique classique il y est
pour beaucoup
on a essayé avec free jazz du rythm and
blues la pop du rock pas du tout le même
effet la musique classique ça les
apaiser regarde plutôt son tu peux
tourner tout autour elles sont toutes
parfaitement calme et puis deviendra
l'été elles seront dans leurs prés
tranquillement personnes viendraient
embêtés hein ah non pâturage tournant
dynamique ici elles reviennent en
prairie tous les 21 jours pour manger
l'herbe quand elle habille suffisamment
poussé quand l'herbe donne sa
quintessence
après elles repartent elles repartent et
ce qui fait qu'on peut avoir jusqu'à 100
bêtes sur un hectare et qu'on change
tous les jours ils y reviennent au bout
de 21 jours
maintenant le fait d'élever ou
naturelles des levées
c'est en tout en fait tout va sur
l'ensemble bien sûr c'est un ensemble et
pour me donner encore un autre exemple
juste avant de se quitter
il me propose une dernière rencontre
locale oblige il m'emmène à quelques
minutes de sa ferme dans la fabuleuse
abbaye des vaux de cernay pour une
petite recette avec nos chefs nous
l'aviez d'easynet est aussi justement il
cuisine les produits d'eric vous aviez
vu que tu as osé beaucoup la viande avec
le beurre au moment de la cuisson c'est
un des secrets senna de secret parce
qu'en fait le beurre ça n'ouvre il a
bien voilà il après sympa nous amène une
belle coloration dessus et il y en a
d'autres des secrets comme ça que tu
pourrais nous dévoiler alors après
cuisson en fait il ya autant de temps de
cuisson que temps de repos ça permet en
fait à la viande de s'attendrir y en a
tout le l'excédent de sang qui s'écoule
d'acorn à une vente d'une jambe de les
voir des coupes etc est parfait alors là
saônoise puisque tu te fournit donc chez
éric quelles sont ses particularités et
pourquoi tu l'a choisi parce que moi
pour moi c'est une viande qui est
justement cas beaucoup de caractère au
niveau fermeté assez poignante qui est
très très tendre en fait mais qu'à un
goût exceptionnel et qui est très
juteuse vous allez voir la dégustation
c'est exceptionnel
pour qu'on va goûter ce à tous les trois
à viège d'ensuite des légumes de saison
et agrément que l'assiette avec des
herbes et des fleurs d'un champ voisin
et ça donne une assiette local plein de
saveurs si vous voulez revoir cette
journée passionnante avec eric retrouver
ses meilleures adresses je vous donne
rendez vous sur terre de france pointent
tv on se retrouve aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux pour les coulisses de l'émission
et je vous dis à très vite pour de
nouvelles rencontres
[Musique]